my name is Samuel Leeds and I want to
officially say if you are not intending
to invest in property in 2018 quite
frankly you are an idiot now before I
tell you why I think you're an idiot let
me just say a big Merry Christmas to you
all
I'm sat in my car currently the reason
is because inside the barn we have a
crazy house we've got family all over
we've got the Zimbabwean side of the
family who were very very noisy we've
got kids we've got burning boxes outside
in the yard so it's absolutely crazy so
I thought I'd sit in the car to explain
to you why you need to be investing in
property and there's gonna be four types
of people who are gonna hate me for this
video and maybe you're one of those four
categories so I'll be revealing that in
the video to see if you are and lastly
I've got a very special gift for you
which is why I'm sat in the car on
Christmas Day to give you this gift
because I really care about my
subscribers and my fans
so the first time people who are not
planning on investing in property who I
think are idiots or we call them the big
crash prophesize these are the people
that say there's gonna be a massive
crash in the economy and properties are
gonna become worthless over the next few
years and it's all gonna be farming
everywhere and you know what these
people are idiots here's why they're
idiots number one is because that is
just not the case we're living on a
small island there's an overpopulation
of people and a shortage of houses so
it's completely ridiculous and moronic
to say that the houses will become
worthless but what about brick ship with
all the people leave what about the
people have we've gone every day into
this country give me a break
I think that wherever there's a
recession there always follows an
expansion wherever there's an expansion
there always follows a recession so
there are parts for instance right now
of London which are dipping in value
because they've doubled in the last six
years and there's other parts that are
going up in value
and one of the houses that I bought five
years ago in Warsaw which I bought it
five years ago and it's gone up by 44%
in the last five years but the same
dooming bloomers were saying this five
years ago so yeah stupid second leg
which is really important is these
people's that say there's a big crash
well even if there was a big crash
people like me and people hopefully like
you make their money from rents so it's
my whole portfolio dipped by 25% it
wouldn't actually affect me at all right
now because in this was playing to sell
them I'm still getting my rent coming in
each month and usually what happens when
properties do go down and there's a
recession because people can't afford to
buy and everything's difficult it
actually means that you get more renters
and rents go up so the whole thing is
completely moronic and the people that
go around saying this usually don't have
an alternative anyway they just like to
scare monger because they have no plan
and they are completely broke if people
are going around saying we crush if
there was a crush that big that ruined
property investors it would ruin
everybody if interest rates put a shot
up back high that would room with people
like me and people like you it would
ruin everybody that couldn't you
couldn't sustain that so I'd love to
know what their plan is if they haven't
got a plan if they're just saying
shouldn't do this and you shouldn't do
that and that's dangerous and that's
dangerous but I am NOT interested anyway
talk to and these are the biggest idiots
of them all these we call them the the
socialist or communist folk that say to
more than two houses is greedy because
what about the poor people that are
struggling to get on the ladder you're
taking away you know what that is just
nonsense people that say buy low rent
high
that's so mean it's so bad on the on the
tenants that is completely ridiculous
let me explain why that's ridiculous
firstly because if you say that to have
more than one house is unfair because
there's people who haven't got enough
then you need to take that not just with
property you need to take that same
philosophy with your money and say
there's limited money in the world so
you shouldn't have more than other
people
in which case the same people that say
you shouldn't have more houses than
other people I'll bet they've got more
money than most people in the world
trust me I know because I've been some
the rural parts of Africa the slums of
India so the whole argument is
completely flawed the bottom line is
there'll always be rich people they'll
always be poor people so you just want
to be a nice rich person you want to get
wealthy by adding value to people and
then when you get wealthy you want to
help the less fortunate the only way you
can get by low rent high is by buying
properties that you've bought smart and
then you rent them out by adding value
you split them up and rent them out room
by room and offer convenient
accommodation for professionals so if
you're not adding value or just trying
to rent as high as you can by being an
idiot landlord you can have empty
properties anyway so that's the first
reason where the argument is flawed it's
also flawed because property investing
is a business your house is your product
your tenant is your customer and in any
business you're only gonna get money by
adding value to people so when I buy a
house and I rent out to somebody that
person wants to enter I'm not being mean
tomorrow forcing them to rent it the
argument is flawed and it's always said
buy broke people and complete hypocrites
and the reason they even say it is
probably because they're just jealous
they don't have any properties
themselves so they go around saying that
you shouldn't have more than X amount
and X amount is probably just the same
size as their portfolio which is usually
none next the third type of people who
are not planning on investing in
property all the people you say that the
government are making it so difficult
with the tax changes and the stamp duty
in all the legislation that making
property investing such a difficult
business that they just give up and
they're gonna move on something else yes
the government all making it harder in
some areas but usually where there's a
rule change here for the bad there's
always a rule change here for the good
and you'll better find a loophole so the
last house that I bought I think
before if at the last two houses that
I've not played any stunts GJ and the
tax changes are very get around about my
buying in a limited company so if you're
one of these people are scared off by
the gun and scale off by the changes I
would just say when people are scared
off that's when you should be greedy and
when people are greedy that's when you
should be scared off so I wouldn't call
you an idiot but what I would say is
just get yourself educated and just work
around those issues rather than turning
away from them and watch how much money
you make as I'm doing as my students
which leads me to my last type of person
the fourth category and it's not so much
that they won't invest in property in
2018 is that they say that they can't
and it's the people that haven't got
money to put down as deposits or they've
got money but they can't get a mortgage
or there's just something stopping them
and I've said to you guys you're not
idiots but you just need to be educated
and taught how to do it there are some
preachers out there say oh no money down
deals are impossible are you just
telling people dreams you know what I
mean about selling people dreams but
when I've done it myself and I see lots
of people doing it after going on my
property investors crash course when
last week I've just worked on a deal
with a guy who couldn't get a mortgage
and I've done a joint venture with him
whereby I've not put any money in and he
hasn't it doesn't have to get a mortgage
and it's like a win-win-win for you know
when this has been done all the time I
can't deny that it is doable even the
biggest investors in the world Donald
Trump you might not like Donald Trump
but he's a serial investor loads of his
deals he's done and he's creatively done
them where there's been no money down
deals it's completely doable it just
needs some creativity which leads me to
my wrap-up which is my gift on Christmas
day to you watching this at home but
before I tell you what that is I just
want to say firstly thank you for the
gift that you've given me thank you for
watching this channel or I've now hit
three thousand plus subscribers which is
just amazing and if you are subscribed
if you comment if you're watching a
follower of this property show then
massive respect big up thank you it's so
cool to be part of a a tribal community
that are really positive and also a real
implementers in property and I've loved
hearing your success stories and just
being part of your journey and you were
also part of my journey as well so thank
you and my gift is I would like to
invite you
complimentary to come and spend two days
with me at the property investors crash
course and you'll walk away probably
with live deals certainly with a really
good action plan where you're ready to
smash 2018 this is pretty much sold out
now and I might not be running this
again so there's only a couple of dates
left and if you click on the link below
you'll be able to see the different
locations I'm not kidding they've pretty
much all sold out I reckon within the
next couple of weeks they'll be
completely gone so do put yourself and
your friend a complimentary ticket to
the property investors crash course and
put together your game plan and how you
can get around the complications I make
more money than you ever thought
possible this year coming through
property so I'll see you next year and
I'd love to see your comments below
don't forget to Like subscribe and share
this video
god bless you have a very Merry
Christmas
you